context on all this let's bring in cbs
news culture and gender contributor jody
cantor who is also a pulitzer
prize-winning
investigative reporter for the new york
times and oh by the way her reporting
helped inspire the me too movement jody
good morning to you good morning how
many years we had you at the table to
talk about topics like this one i think
we're coming up on the fourth
anniversary
so let's get into it governor cuomo his
strategy seems to be to deny deny deny
buy himself some time what do you make
of that
i think that politically he has a very
difficult exit
strategy and on the one hand at the time
may advantage him but on the other hand
more and more and more is coming out and
you know that report that was released
by the attorney general
last week contained so much information
and we're continuing to see the
implications of all of that
play out including for time's up which
is the organization that was founded
to combat these problems in the wake of
the weinstein scandal
and yet had as one of its closest allies
governor andrew cuomo that's what's so
interesting about this case they're all
different in their way but
governor cuomo appeared to be a champion
of the me too movement and an ally of
victims and now he's allegedly creating
victims in his wake how do people
reconcile that
i think that's one of the hardest to
fathom things about this
situation because we've all heard a lot
of these metoo allegations over the
years
but what is so distinct about these is
that
as this was exploding as there was a
global reckoning
the governor of new york which was
ground zero as we know
uh for this reckoning was allegedly
committing the same offenses and when
you
when you look at the dates we lined up
the report against the public record
the dates are astonishing there was a
day two years ago almost to the day in
august 2019
where on on one day the governor signed
really important legislation protecting
women we're talking about
landmark sexual harassment protections
that women had sought for years
the next day he allegedly
continued his pursuit of that state
trooper
jonathan what what has to change because
there are laws that are being enacted
but is it beyond that is it more of a
cultural issue that has to change so
somebody like
governor cuomo isn't committing offenses
like this well
you know i don't think anyone was under
the illusion that the harvey weinstein
story or the metoo reckoning was going
to solve these problems but i think that
this is prompting
a deeper layer of searching about
whether we do
have the right tools in place if you
look at you know part of what's
fascinating about that report is that
it's kind of an anatomy
of the governor's office and how it
functioned right
even in this very official work
environment there weren't effective ways
to make complaints
the attorney general says people were
scared constantly of retaliation
and so all these years later we're still
asking the basic questions of
do women feel that they have a safe way
to report
and you know another terrifying thing
about this story is how close
it came to remaining secret i mean look
at the powerful interview that was on
this show
yesterday if you look at the timeline a
lot of these women
intention originally thought they were
going to take these secrets to the grave
even in the metoo era and how many
stories have gone to the grave or will
be kept secret regardless yeah and
you mentioned already uh roberta kaplan
the prominent lawyer
four times up who was advising governor
cuomo
about all of this explain to people who
may not understand time's up is supposed
to be
in women's corners so this is the really
complicated interesting situation
time's up founded to fight these
problems
who becomes one of their biggest allies
governor andrew cuomo
this organization gets really
substantive stuff
done with the governor in the course of
doing that
they develop a relationship that gets
him that gets them in trouble
not because they were working with him
on legislation there's nobody who really
thinks that was the wrong thing to do
but because once these allegations
started to dribble out time's up
got a little bit too involved in
advising essentially
roberta kaplan and tina chen the head
gave some feedback on a kind of op-ed
uh letter that that that is now coming
under question in the in the eg report
and also roberta kaplan who is this
powerhouse progressive attorney she
helped
get gay marriage established it turns
out that
one of her firm's clients is melissa de
rosa
the former cuomo aide she resigned a few
days ago
who has now been accused of helping
smear
one of the women so people are asking
time's up
which side were you on in this whole
thing
remarkable you said back in 2019 in the
wake of me too everything's changed
but nothing's changed probably feel the
same way jodie cantor
as always thank you very much appreciate
it thank you